welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Anna
Ziya Rouge niya who is assistant
professor in the Department of Music at
Yale University her research brings a
history of musical forms and notation
into dialogue with medieval literature
iconography and the history of ideas her
work has appeared in the leading
journals of her field today we'll talk
with professors I aru's niya about her
book the monstrous new art divided forms
in the late medieval motet for which was
awarded the macmillan centers Gatiss
myth International Book Prize welcome
professor Thank You Marilyn it's great
to be here let's begin with an overview
of your book please tell us about it
well it's a book about the motet and the
motet is it's a genre of song it's
actually the longest lived musical genre
probably the earliest motets are from
the 13th century Bach was writing motets
and composers today are still writing
motets but for me when I think about the
motet in the early 14th century what I
mean by that is a shortish song for
three or four voices that has words okay
which is not very specific but it's the
words that are key here so earlier today
my students my doctoral students well
Watson and PIPA oven them got together
with me and we actually recorded a motet
that will play now so you can see a
little more what I'm talking about okay
great let's take a look
so what you might hear there is that
each of us is singing a different set of
words oh also there's a lot of words
going on and so the name of the genre
motet that comes actually from the
French word for mo forward as well and
so my big research question for this
book is how do the musical structures of
motets relate to the words that are in
them okay that is given this emphasis on
words in the genre what what are the
musical sort of consequences of whatever
I'm given motet might be about and
especially the question is sort of
sharpened by the fact that motet said
this time our best mr. pretty strange
things like when we think about what
songs are about today maybe they're
about love or maybe they're their
political songs but this motet is about
this sort of horse or like a half horse
half man evil creature named Koval whose
name stands for a bunch of vices
flattery avarice villainy changefulness
that sort of stuff and he represents
everything that's wrong with the world
and there's a book written about him in
13 10 13 14 and then a manuscript made
of this book with lots of music in it
including this motet and so they're
singing that the actual lowest voice is
in the mouth of this kind of evil horse
that is corrupting Christendom and it's
corrupting France and and it's and so
and the the form of the piece is also in
a certain kind of approximate way
actually giving us a sense of the form
of this evil horse monster thing and so
a long time ago I started wondering why
do they write the motets of other things
there and what that's about and how
what's given this emphasis on words and
also an emphasis on the newest sort of
musical developments in musical notation
and music structure how do words and
music relate here so this motet that we
just saw
is in French are they often in French or
are there other languages the in the
repertory I study there either in French
or in Latin or sometimes both at the
same time so one of the voices might be
a French and one might be in love okay
so you mentioned the lower voice was of
the monster what are the other two
voices in this case they're of the the
people who are living in this world that
he is corrupting and they're just
they're doleful and they're sad because
everything is wrong everything is bad I
mean it's an interesting story for a lot
of reasons it feels very very
contemporary they're complaining that
everything is turned upside down and the
good people are being punished and the
bad people are being rewarded and they
just don't know which way to turn or
what to do with themselves so it's it's
a social critique I was going to say it
sounds very political to me it is very
political yeah and so that's one of the
functions so starting from pieces like
this I got into I found other motets
from this time that were about monsters
or the monstrous or hybrid creatures
that were part something and print
something else and it turns out that one
of the functions of the monster and the
monstrous in medieval thought is to do
criticism it's sort of it's a way to do
to do criticism sort of viscerally just
kind of like if you think of caricature
and the way that caricature brings out
certain features to make people less
human and more more sort of menacing or
funny or whatever that the monstrous is
used to highlight kind of everything
that's wrong with the world and to put
it into sharp relief okay a couple
things come to mind I want to know you
look at specific composers but in your
talking about the kind of the political
color of the motet it I'm wondering if
people wrote them with with imagery
because they perhaps were afraid of
saying of coming out and speaking in
their own voice so using a monster the
image of a monster to really convey what
they're feeling themselves without
perhaps being persecuted I mean is that
a possibility at all uh III think so
that if you criticize one person then
you're only criticizing one person but
if you criticize an allegory of the most
the filthiest worst most corrupt
possible creature then everybody in
their own mind goes to a particular
place and so it I think that criticism
that's then allegorical terms ends up
being more powerful because it can it
lashes out in multiple directions at
once and ultimately has more staying
power because here we are and so the the
story of favela feels very very fresh
right now Lavelle is this is he's a
yellow hair and horse and he's a just a
horse but but people start they raise
him up to be a leader and they are
petting him and they're loving him and
and and and he gets more kind of puffed
up on their praise and decides that he's
going to take over France and so and
then a lot of the manuscript is
basically using this story to to point
at everything that's actually wrong and
saying the clergy are corrupt and the
rulers don't care and the rich just want
to be Richard the expense of the poor
and all this stuff and because it's a
story about a horse in this fictional
land that happens to also be Paris and
the 1313 tens but because it's um it's
it's a story I think it actually has
more staying power than if it were just
straight up you know right and what a
universal theme to really which really
is interesting yeah in some ways
comforting to see that somebody in the
13 teens thought we are the world is
really almost ending I mean everything
it couldn't be worse it must be almost
the apocalypse because creatures that
are so unsuited to be rulers are being
put in the highest positions of
government and we are really it's the
Antichrist must be at hand and on the
one hand it's comforting to know that it
didn't end then and hopefully it's not
going to end now on the other hand you
think God haven't we been here before so
many times exactly yeah so I am
interested to know how you became
interested in this what led you to write
the book
so actually faux vel this this weird
horse kind of was the beginning of it
because actually even when I was an
undergrad I was a junior and I was
studying I was at Wesleyan but I was
studying abroad at Oxford and in Oxford
you have instead of classes you have
tutors and you sort of go through things
a little bit more at your own pace and
at a particular tutor gave me a call
number for this book to take out one day
and gave it to the librarian and um and
they gave me this giant book I mean it's
probably this big and it's it's a
facsimile a photocopy of this manuscript
that lives in Paris and and it was all
about this the the the disastrous rise
of this evil horse and it had it was a
hugely lavish manuscript beautifully
decorated pages and I thought who are
these people why are you putting so much
creative energy and musical creativity
and interest into telling the story of
this monstrous horse and so that that
then led me to start thinking about
these motets and thinking about the ways
they use the monstrous and and
eventually that that kind of led to this
book okay let's talk about the composers
that you use in the book and and kind of
about your methodology so the book is
not composer centered in fact when I
started writing my dissertation I
decided I wasn't gonna really think
about composers at all partly because
most of his music survives anonymously
in the manuscripts okay they just
weren't in the habit of attributing
pieces or am putting composers names and
the margins and the way that you start
to see by the end of the 15th century
but several composers do keep coming up
as I as I continued my research there
was two especially one young DiMaggio
and we know what he wrote because he he
collected big collected works
manuscripts of all his stuff so we
actually know exactly what he wrote and
he is interested in the goddess Fortuna
who is a condom monster because she's
split down the center and half of her as
like old and and and and and and and
scowling and miserable and half of her
is beautiful and young
so she's a kind of vertically split
monster and my show writes a lot about
her but the other composer that writes
about a bigger variety of deformed
creatures and and writes about them a
variety of what you might say deformed
motets so he's using musical form in a
particular way is somebody named if you
need to be clean and he's actually the
subject of my next book ok so how did
you find all of these motets I mean how
many are there could you quantify them I
mean are there thousands or really not
that many not that many I guess in the
14th century if you thinking about
French motets that are kind of related
and in this idiom and they share sources
and they share composers it's maybe 90
or 100 pieces and of them in this book I
probably deal seriously with 10 or 15 so
it's a small subset of the repertory but
they're very rich partly because you
have you know two or three texts for a
piece and then they the bottom voice
often is actually taken from Gregorian
chant from plain chant so that gives you
then another context in which to think
ok well this isn't just a piece of music
it's a piece of news that comes from
somewhere so what knowledge does it
bring with it into the piece and the
same for the upper voices they may have
quotations in them from songs from
classical literature there's a lot of
vidiian quotation and illusion so it
they are very dense texts and very dense
musical objects so there's a lot to do
with them so I imagine you you have
translated the ones that you're using in
your book into English I guess there's a
lot of translation involved and there's
also sort of musical translation the
motet survived in notation that is is in
a lot of ways like ours like you would
look at them and you say okay that's
musical notation but then the details of
it get a little bit fuzzy so you have to
learn how to read it the older notation
and then think about translating it into
a modern notation that your readers can
follow so there's both there's a editing
and translation of texts from both
French and Latin into English and then
also translating of older music
notations into new or musical notations
and then I imagine when you're when the
reader
is reading your book they have to they
must have to imagine how the song sounds
or do you provide a way for them to hear
the music as well so it was really
important for me to provide a way for my
readers to hear the music
partly because I wanted this book to be
not just for musicologists and certainly
not just for musicologists who think
about music of the 14th century but I
wanted it to be comprehensible to the
kinds of readers whom I'm reading and
doing my research art historians
historians of intellectual culture
historians of of various medieval sort
of types and so I think all of the music
examples are recorded and they are
online and then it can be listened to
and that was through through a various
grants I received to do that and it's
been um it's been generally well
received I think and I'm really glad
they're there because we want to since
we introduced apin Airy work is so
important right now not only should we
be reading in different disciplines but
it seems important to write then work
that is accessible to those same broad
disciplines hopefully without
sacrificing the specificity of you know
the kinds of analysis generally I am
interested to know during the time
period where these motets were being
sung did they did they have special
singers sing them or was it you know
where people would go
was it a performance or you know did
people sing these in their day to day
lives kind of thing it's a great
question and it's really hard to know
exactly because we we don't have the
kinds of rich accounts that we would
like to have we have offhand comments
like somebody saying well I you know I
one time I was at a at a what have you
call it uh a small gathering of
discerning people so essentially a
cocktail party right and and motets were
performed so I think my my best guess
and the best guess of people in my field
is that these were sung as entertainment
by clerics
so sort of the the educated the sort of
the the the nerd class you know like the
secretaries of kings and of bishops and
their themselves were clerics but maybe
not at least often not deeply in the
church they weren't necessarily
cloistered they were sort of secular
clerics so that's interesting so did was
it exclusively men who were singing
these motets we know that women saying
in the 14th century
they probably saying motets it's again
it's it's hard to know but there's
there's enough evidence of women's
singers and some of them probably quite
talented and certainly courtly songs and
what heads are they're kind of funny
they're not courtly they're not really
about love as much they sometimes it can
be and they're also not exactly
religious though they can be they occupy
this strange category where they can be
about just really many different things
and that also makes it hard to place
them in a in a cultural context because
they're so different from each other
okay yeah I was actually was going to
ask were you able to in reading the
lyrics correlate any of those lyrics to
what was going on politically or
culturally or socially during that time
period
absolutely so some some Oh tests are in
praise of specific rulers whether they
be Pope's or kings and so then that
that's easy is okay well then maybe this
was for the occasion of this this Pope's
ordination or for this kings for a
particular celebration or something
though even then it's often hard to
pinpoint exactly which one you know
seven hundred years later but sometimes
they are in honor of saints and then the
Saints will have been dead for hundreds
of years or more and then you have to
ask yourself to whom is the saint
important now and why and it ultimately
you know tends to be political in that
way the and then you know the more some
motets are just really especially V
trees maquettes tend to just be social
critique you know a critique against the
groveling courtier so the person at
court who just has no independence they
just tow the line and wouldn't you
rather be your own person wouldn't you
rather think your own thoughts even if
it
and having less money and less prestige
and that kind of a piece because of its
universality is absolutely impossible to
place as yeah yeah but isn't any time
it's fascinating though that people are
having those thoughts you know so far
we're back so it is amazing really so
your book kind of has a brings a new
perspective to medieval and renaissance
music so why don't you talk a little bit
about how your work is a little bit
different and a different approach from
what is out there in terms of scholarly
publications well my work builds on a
lot of other work and so it's it's
certainly standing on the shoulders of
giants for sure
I think the thing that the sort of
broadest questions I raise our questions
about what song is and how we can think
of it and so one of the things I do is
is suggest that instead of thinking of
of motets and other medieval songs as
these sort of monumental floating things
the way we think of a Beethoven symphony
Lydia ger who's a philosopher has talked
about the the work concept that there's
a museum of musical work somewhere in
our minds and that's where Beethoven's
Beethoven's symphonies live and whereas
these motets they seemed to change with
the times they were updated they they
were actually going for a kind of
immediate relevance and they were much
more concerned as what was going on
right then they weren't trying to be
immortal but they also were not
completely ephemeral they they had a
sort of cultural staying power so I
offer a creature concept of the medieval
work in my book that's sort of trying to
say well here are motets that kind of
embody the monsters that they're about
and what does that tell us what does it
give us if we think about a piece of
music as a as a creature as opposed to
as a as a as something that is like a
like a building right and the other
thing I do is I think broadly about the
relationship between words and music and
so we have words to describe how music
and words relate in later repertories
like in six
three matter goals so Italian songs from
the sixteenth century we often talk
about text painting which is when you
get a word like up or skies and you go
up the musical line goes up or or you
thing about the abyss and you go down
and that's a very local relationship
between word and tone and that doesn't
happen very much in medieval music and
so if you then look at medieval music
and ask whether it does the kinds of
things that later music does to relate
word in tome you see that it doesn't it
doesn't do that because there are later
things and so my question was well what
does it do and so I posit a broader
relation between word and tone that's
not on the level of the individual note
in the word but actually on the level of
the piece of music and it's broader
message and then I think about the ways
in which medieval intellectual
traditions like analogy support that
kind of relation so ultimately what
would you like the reader to take away
from your book I would like them to to
know that the people who wrote these
motets did so very carefully I did so
very playfully but also very seriously
that they were thinking about the
biggest issues of their day and and also
the biggest musical issues of their day
the new possibilities made available by
developments in notation new formal
possibilities and they were constructing
works of art that that put these things
into this created encounters I guess
between between important things in life
and important things in music and so
it's worth our time looking at these
with the kinds of detail and the kinds
of care that that really carefully
constructed works of art command thank
you so much for being here with us say
this has been fascinating thank you for
having me for more information about
professors I aru's niya and her work
please visit our website at Macmillan
report yale.edu be sure to join us again
for another
SOTA the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at you